I'm Barbara Meade I'm one of the owners
here at politics and prose and this
evening I'm well welcoming Steve and
Joel Trachtenberg the president emeritus
of George Washington University and he's
come to talk to us about his new memoir
big man on campus in which he's
distilled the wisdom that has come in 30
years of college presidencies 19 of them
at George Washington and along the way
he's written 15 psych books in gotten 15
honorary degrees quite an accomplishment
in dr. Trachtenberg reflections on
trustees faculty students alumni all
four constituents that he serves and
that he reflects upon of what did they
expect from a university president and
you would be surprised to learn such
diverse attributes as the financial
sense of J Pierpont Morgan the
inventiveness of Edison's the rhetorical
ability of Churchill the loving kindness
of mother Teresa and the patience of job
as he says it's a lot of water to carry
and most candidates have only two
shoulders well but dr. Trachtenberg has
really thrived at George Washington as
their president and the university
really strived under his leadership he
really in the 19 years that he was there
he took it into a world-class university
and most of all he just loved the job
and he brought such an insect's
infectious enthusiasm to every chapter
of his tenure that he's here to tell us
about and maybe we'll hear a few secrets
of his success that he's smart a member
of Phi Beta Kappa certainly helped but
most importantly he has a humor of a
Groucho Marx which has allowed him to
maintain his sanity and some of the more
frenzied time and I'm sure we'll also
hear this evening
sub wise words of absurdity some good
liners that have established perspective
and thwarted some potentially ominous
standoffs so here's dr. Trachtenberg
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much Barbara
for your kind introduction and thank you
to all of you for being here I'm
delighted that we're all gathered at
politics and prose and and it's it's
very satisfying to see so many old
friends here but also complete strangers
who I feel have no particular in debt to
me and and are here on a voluntary basis
being being asked to read at politics
and prose is a rite of passage for an
author and I'm honored to be among the
chosen if you'll permit me as I was
coming in somebody asked me what I
myself was reading these days and I was
reminded of the fact that many years ago
when I did a Dewar's scotch commercial
they asked me what book I was reading at
the time and I said it was let them eat
promises by Nick cuts and as it turns
out I am now reading Nick cuts book
judgment days about Lyndon Johnson and
Martin Luther King and the 1964 Civil
Rights Act and the 1965 Voting Rights
Act and as I was as I was going through
it I thought it's it's an awful shame
that Obama and Clinton hadn't read this
this book early on about these laws that
changed America and we might have saved
ourselves one of the controversies
during the run-up to the to the election
in any rate I recommend Nick Carson's
book and I hope you'll read that but
after you finished mine
Barbara you and Karla Cohen have have
created an institution here in upper
Northwest that is for many of us the
shop around the corner
if a person comes here and can't find
something special to read then he or she
is not really looking for something to
read I know I'm preaching to the
converted as I look at this group you
you'll look a little nearsighted and and
therefore it's probably incumbent upon
all of us to support this wonderful
independent bookstore as you heard last
year I turned my my life upside down I
relinquished the office of an
institution I had had the privilege of
leading for almost 20 years George
Washington University and in so doing I
I moved that office which turned out to
be no small feat I don't throw anything
away and and all of it accumulated in
the in the president's office that was a
commodious office it turns out that
ex-presidents gets smaller offices and
so I had to dispose of 30 cartons of
books and the mementos of almost two
decades of office there were pictures at
least 50 of them almost all of them of
photographs with me standing next to
zelich or or somebody somebody who
looked pretty famous I some of them to
my to when my new office I have one at
corn ferry now and and there is a
picture of me standing with the Dalai
Lama and that turns out to have really
impressed my colleagues on on K Street I
moved a lot of artifacts George
Washington University tchotchkes and and
hippopotamuses and all sorts of other
things and of course the most important
thing I packed up were my memories not
only did I relocate my office but Fran
and I on the same day that I was moving
out of the office she
thus out of the George Washington
University President's House
what the student newspaper likes to
refer to as a mansion into a home a home
of our own
now I underline the of our own because
it is the first time in our married life
and Francine is my first wife and we
have been married for 36 years 37 this
year coming up and it's the first time
in all those years that we are not
living in public housing all these years
at at Boston University and the
University of Hartford and at George
Washington University I've been living
in institutional accommodations so you
can imagine the relocation meant picking
up the books and the memos and the
pictures and the artifacts as well as
the clothes and the dishes and the shoes
and the hats and the computers and all
all the other stuff of life fortunately
the children the children Adam and Ben
had already moved out of the house and
we didn't have to worry about them and
again of course I moved the memories for
about a year or year and a half before I
officially stepped down as president I
found myself reminiscing recalling
interesting parts of my life things that
shake the person that I am today and and
the institution's I had the good fortune
that to be part of and I was telling
stories to friends at lunch and to my
racquetball partners and to Francine at
dinner and then one day I said half
joking maybe I should write a book
fortunately I had the good luck to say
that in front of tansy bloomer she's
here some dishes in the green put your
hand in the air tansy and it turns out
that tansy is a writer who helps to
frame biographies and memoirs and she
cooked this book out of me using tape
recorders and and
multiple cups of coffee over a period of
a year it's my book it's my book and you
can hear my voice when you pick it up
but it wouldn't be a book at all if it
weren't for tansy and I want to express
my gratitude to her and it it wouldn't
be the book it is without my publisher
mark Gumpert Susi air from Simon and
Schuster he's the head of touchstone
press and he's wearing a GW baseball cap
so you can't miss him
mark thank you thank you very much he
guided the book and and me through
several neurotic stages from conception
to delivery to bookstores all over the
country and particularly to politics and
prose so I want to thank I want to thank
mark and Francine it goes without saying
the mother of my children I actually
thanked her in the dedication most of my
life I've been a Adventists Tory teller
and this book is full of tall tales some
of them are personal from my childhood
in Brooklyn some from my travels around
the world and others from from daily
life and there are the professional
stories as well about the people I
worked with and the institution's with
which I was associated the goal of this
book is not to tell you how wonderful
mr. Vogel was as my shop teacher in the
eighth grade at PS 254 although he was
very very wonderful there is some
dispute about whether his name was Vogel
or Fogel and several of my classmates
remember it one way and others another
whatever his name was there were lessons
that I was taught from his class to talk
about life and how it matters if one
takes responsibility for one's own
actions I was a terrible student in shop
and inevitably things didn't work out
and I used to go to mr. Vogel Vogel and
and I would say look mr. ball
it broke and he would say Trachtenberg
it didn't break you rocket and there's a
world of wisdom in that observation my
stories of vehicles for sharing what I
learned educational exercises after all
a college president may be called many
things and Lord knows I have been called
many things and one of those things I'm
pleased to say is a teacher so let me
share with you some anecdotes years ago
I read about a little College in
Connecticut that closed because it can
no longer pay it's paid bills it no
longer could pay the faculty it couldn't
stay afloat fine financially and the
hartford courant
the local paper published an article
about the demise of the college and
quoted a faculty member who said I
noticed that my classes were getting
smaller and smaller and I thought what a
splendid thing because I was able to
teach smaller and smaller groups of
students it never occurred to me that
that could be a sign that the school
might fold I was astounded he said I
that that quote and I was then the
president of the University of Hartford
and I thought that that's a special
observation the innocence of the comment
might seem rather stunning to a
university administrator it's not it's
really not unusual for people to react
this way because most of them great
believe that colleges and universities
are here forever
they don't fail well do they
universities are very special places
their structure and their customs are
rooted in earlier times medieval times
and we're trying to preserve many of
these ancient institutions and
traditions while living in the 21st
century but we cannot ignore or hold an
arm's-length
all aspects of modern life in fact
according to john sexton my colleague
and the president of new york university
there are 85 institutions in the world
that exist as they did 500 years ago
these are in no special order the
English Parliament the papacy 8 Swiss
cantons and of the remaining 70 70 are
universities now Bob Dylan informs us
that the times are changing only a
handful of colleges and universities
have genuinely significant endowments
whatever you may read about Harvard's 37
billion dollars most universities have
modest investment funds and these school
survives because of the tuition dollars
that come in each semester I want you to
think of a movie theater buy a ticket at
the counter you go in and see the film
they tear the ticket and half that's how
they pay for the enterprise they are
customer driven and that's just true of
universities as it is of the cinema
whether we like the term customer or not
students and their families are
increasing their demands that colleges
deliver more and better new luxury
services and accommodations over and
above anything required for a quality
academic experience along with the
first-rate academics superb faculty and
small classes universities are being
driven to provide an extraordinary level
of material support including campus
food approaching Michelin standards it
won't it won't surprise me to see a star
in knife fork a rating system listed on
the front page of the college catalogs
in the years to come following the lead
of the Princeton Princeton Review
gymnasium gymnasiums at universities are
approaching beauty spa status with
masseuse and personal trainers offered
as well as state-of-the-art equipment to
tone every part of the body classroom
activities hone the mind and during the
after-school hours after class hours the
body is pampered we see a world that
compares favorably to
gated communities in palm beach in cute
including drug abuse and checks from
home if you're a student paying high
tuition figures that reach these days
into the stratosphere it is not
unreasonable that like Johnny Rocco who
you will remember from Key Largo you
asked for more MORE he said I want more
more choices in the dining room better
workout equipment larger and better
dormitory rooms better libraries and if
you are the college and the prospective
students tell you they will only enroll
only enroll in your classes if you give
them more and more then you feel
compelled to accommodate while raising
the tuition in order to have the funds
to pay for all the customer demands a
personal story my father sold life
insurance for the Metropolitan Life
Insurance Company he was a
first-generation immigrant came from
Odessa in the Ukraine and he worked hard
he was out of the house most evenings
and often on weekends calling on clients
and periodically he would take me with
him to show me what he did to put the
bread on the table and of course to
discourage me from becoming an insurance
salesman he made his steady income he
never spent much money on frills
he was as we would say in Brooklyn
comfortable but not wealthy every dollar
every dollar counted so fast forward on
a weekend in 1968 my father called up
and said he had free time and he'd like
to visit me in Boston I was then a baby
Dean at Boston University and we had a
lovely dinner on Friday night and
Saturday morning my father was up at the
crack of dawn and he suggested we go get
breakfast and there was an International
House of Pancakes nearby and he loved
pancakes and so we set out on the way
out of the apartment I collected all all
of my dirty shirts from the past week
and I put them in a pillowcase
to drop off at the laundry on the way to
breakfast my father and I now sit down
and we order pancakes and while we're
waiting for them to show up I see my
father looks very moody so I drew him
out a little I'm now starting to become
concerned that he's there on some agenda
that he doesn't want to share with me
and I say dad there's a dark cloud over
your head uh what's on your mind he said
well he said I couldn't help noticing
that you didn't count the shirts before
you gave them for the laundry
he said that's that's not a good thing
so I said to tell you the truth dead
I've got a philosophy about that kind of
thing
he said that's wonderful he said I'm in
learn and share it with me so I said
well if you count the shirts if you
count the shirts going into the laundry
it follows you must count the shirts
coming out of the laundry otherwise you
wasted your time counting them going in
if you count the shirts coming out there
are three possible outcomes exactly the
same number of shirts in and exactly the
same number of shirts out in which case
you wasted your time counting in and out
the second possibility is you've got
more shirts coming out this is not
likely but but it's possible in which
case it's really somebody else's problem
so if you gave them ten you got eleven
you not have to go through the eleven
shirts pick out the worst one and give
it back so if you're going to give it
back which an honorable person has to do
why'd you have to bother counting in and
out you still ended up at the same ten
shirts you wasted your time the third
possibility is fewer shirts you gave ten
you got nine your shirt try having done
the counting you have to go back to the
laundry and say to the man listen I have
to tell you I gave you ten shirts you
gave me back nine
the first thing that happens is he no
longer speaks English secondly he points
to a sign in a language you can't read
and it informs you if you can get
somebody to translate it that he only
pays ten dollars for lost shirts you are
paying thirty forty dollars for a shirt
twenty dollars
so you're thinking is I paid twenty
dollars for the shirt now I'm losing ten
dollars on the shirt you're unhappy
because he lost the shirt you feel
obliged to take your business someplace
else the new laundry is four blocks away
it's more expensive it's not as good
they put too much starch in they don't
put enough starch it's very annoying and
you sorry you have got into this in the
first place
so I said all this to my father and then
that the clothes you know I said look
during the course during the course of a
lifetime
how many shirts can a person lose you're
losing $10 on a shirt in the course of
an entire lifetime you lose ten shirts
see you down $100 you can amortize the
hundred dollars over a lifetime and you
don't have to count the shirts going any
of the count the shirts coming here so
my father reflected on this and he says
that's that's your philosophy of life I
said yes he said you know I have a
philosophy of life also on this topic I
said really what is it he said it must
be nice to have a rich papa
is a story about about some George
Washington University students right
when I had the privilege of being
president to George Washington I used to
encourage students to talk to me and I
would I would hold office hours on a
regular basis and and I put an
advertisement in the student newspaper
and invite them to come in and sit down
and we'd give them a cup of coffee and
we'd schmooze and students used to show
up for these and they used to feel free
to tell me what was good and bad about
the university largely complaints at
least in the beginning as we got nearer
and nearer to the end of my tenure they
started making compliments in any case
one year two youngsters coming in
wearing identical blue blazers visited
with me and it turns out they explained
they were the captain and the co-captain
of the GW sailing team and they began to
tell me about the sailing team and I
said hold off for a second I've been
here 1012 years and even know we had a
sailing team so it turns out sailing is
a very low visibility sport that GW and
the reason the reason it's a low
visibility sport is they never sail at
GW and the reason they never sail at GW
is they have no boats sailing teams it
turns out participate in what are called
regattas and these regattas are hosted
by universities and the host university
supplies the visiting team with boats
because it's too difficult to move boats
from city to city and university to
university so our team the GW sailing
team specialized in being a visiting
team
they would go to Philadelphia they'd
visit the University of Pennsylvania and
they'd be given boats to use for the
competition so I listen to all this and
I said well how do you practice they
said well well we we don't we don't
practice this is you don't practice you
can't be very good they said well we're
not that's what makes us so popular as a
visiting team I'm a type-a personality I
insisted that I buy them boats and in
return I got a t-shirt so they told
people I urge them not to tell anybody
but they told people and people found
out I bought votes for the GW sailing
team so a couple of weeks later I'm
visited by a couple of other youngsters
and they introduced themselves they're
from the GW equestrian team so I see a
pattern I see a pattern development so
the nice thing about boats is that they
don't eat horses by contrast and then
after they eat so I sent in the
equestrian team listen I'll help you
with the rental fees but you're on your
own with the horses I'm not I'm not
buying any horses first year I came to
Washington amends our men's basketball
team was one and 27 this is one win and
27 losses I thought this was
unacceptable and I had to coach in and
we talked and I suggested he was perhaps
in the wrong line of work
and I offered to introduce them to my
father who would have perhaps given him
a job with the Metropolitan Life
Insurance Company III am NOT a zealous
when it comes to university sports but I
think it's important that GW sports
teams have a plausible season I think
universities that know they are putting
youngsters out to play in
intercollegiate sports who cannot win
who are simply too weak to to ever
prevail in the competition twenty seven
and one I think it's a mild form of
child abuse and and I think it also
suggests that you don't have pride in
yourself I think it's imperative that a
university president care about the
academics of an institution but I tell
you the truth if you don't care about
the athletics and you neglect it and you
let the kids play without the support of
the institution it says something about
your values and so and so I look for
plausibility I love to go to the NCAA
every few years but but it's not life
and death for me
a record with more wins than losses
means the team feels competitive plays
with passion tries to win every game and
from the fans perspective it's likely
they'll see a win or they'll or not but
one in twenty seven it seems to me hard
to justify and hard to watch sports at
GW are fun they're intensely competitive
but they're not pathological
traditionally bonus coaches coaches get
a bonus if their teams make it to the
tournaments
I built into all the contracts of the
coaches I recruited that the bonuses be
given to the coach when they want
tournaments of course but also when
they're students when the players got
their degrees graduated on time and and
I thought that was important optically
and also a statement of my own my own
values I served as a university
president for thirty years and on a
I enjoyed it at least 25 of them I had
the opportunity to meet smart and
interesting people my own my own faculty
of course people from the United States
visitors from abroad presidents
government leaders policymakers royalty
some with countries some without Nobel
Prize winners authors of renowned
Hollywood Hollywood stars universities
bring together an outstanding collection
of people from the eager freshman to the
emeritus professor to the visiting
scholar every day someone is talking
about something else that's quite
extraordinary a new invention a classic
book a star rising in the sky or in
politics I can't imagine a more
fascinating environment in which to
spend one's career I've been very
privileged blessed indeed this book
which I'm urging you all to buy before
you leave here tonight is about those
years and about where I believe higher
education has to move in the next decade
so it can make it successfully through
what I anticipate to be tumultuous years
in the 21st century
change today happens at a rate of speed
unknown to the generations who preceded
us a statement that has probably been
made by people in every one of the last
hundred years which makes it no less
true ever since the era when time
started to move faster than a speeding
bullet we've been anticipating that
we're going faster and faster and indeed
we have been one of the great strengths
of our colleges and universities is that
knowledge is passed from master to
student in much the same way as it has
been for seven hundred years and one of
the great weaknesses of our colleges and
universities is that knowledge is passed
on from master to student in much the
same way as it has has been for over 700
years
what is tradition to one person may seem
rigidity to another I suspect we all
agree with James Madison who I am
informed said education is the true
foundation of civil liberty what we
disagree on is how
going to get that education I'm indebted
to you all for your courtesy and for
coming here tonight and it's wonderful
to see you and I'd be pleased to stand
for questions if you have any thank you
thank you sir with the rising cost of
tuition and our desire to see all
students who wish to pursue a college
education how do we provide adequate
scholarship for all interested students
well I think it's a combination of
getting appropriate funding from the
government from philanthropy but I think
also the universities have to take on
some responsibility for running
themselves more more economically more
efficiently I mentioned before that we
are medieval institutions with medieval
traditions and that surely is true what
we also do live in an age of electronics
and computers and they can help us to do
the job in ways that were unavailable in
earlier in earlier times it's in fact
been argued that place-based
universities will become obsolete in the
in the 21st century and that people will
stay at home or someplace else and
simply get their education and a
home-based way with a computer I hope
that that never happens because I think
that the socialization of of university
experience is important perhaps as the
as the academic and experience as part
of learning process but but I think it's
a question of the government the the
people of the United States who I think
can become very skeptical I must say
about higher education recognizing how
imperative is for us now and and into
the future
but the universities have to accept
their share of the burden of
demonstrating that the resources that
they've been given by taxpayers and
parents and students being spent in an
informed and and a fiduciary way thank
you
yes sir do you see the the tenure system
at university is changing into something
else and and if you do do you think that
will affect intellectual freedom for a
long time I was an antagonist of tenure
and thought and thought it it probably
ought to be retired or at least put on
sabbatical I have as I've matured
reconsidered that that position I think
there are of course mistakes made in in
tenure God knows look at the divorce
rate in this country but but but it may
be a price that we have to pay in order
to have some of the freedoms that you're
implicitly referring to in your question
the question then is do we have to have
it exactly as we have it when I was a
youngster and first came into university
life tenure was as it is now granted
mostly at about age 33 or 35 somebody
earns a PhD they work in the university
for five six seven years they get tenure
and then they get on with their career
but it had a terminus generally people
got the tenure at about 35 and they and
they retired conventionally or their
contract ran out at 65 and so it was
functionally a 30-year contract and I
don't remember people objecting to that
at the time in fact what happened is an
outside element entered into the
discussion the federal government our
government passed a law saying that age
related to the retirement related to age
would no longer be permitted and and
while we fussed about it a little in the
universities we never made it clear I
don't think that that would have an
effect on us that was distinguishable
from football teams and and law firms
and other kinds of enterprise which
didn't have tenure and the result is
that tenure now is a lifetime
appointment and that's probably a
mistake I'm going to tell you in all
candor I am NOT at 70
as robust and as vigorous as I was at 65
and I don't anticipate that at 75 I'm
going to get stronger and so I I think
we ought to be candid about the fact
that as we get older we become less
robust I don't have anything complicated
to suggest except the restoration a
restoration of a term to tenure I think
it would protect academic freedom and
and and all the implications of that
every bit as vigorously as it presently
does but at 65 I think it should convert
to a year to year
evergreen I don't think we ought to
throw people out at 65 as they say I'm
70 and I would have been gone five years
ago if that was the case and I hope to
keep going from the lady or 90 or
something but I think it's fair for
institutions and and individuals to take
a look at their relationship after 65 on
a year-by-year basis and make a judgment
about whether we want to continue it and
I don't think it ought to call for
hearings and all of the debt arises that
comes with the legal process if you're
trying to break somebody somebody's can
you for cause GW is found in 1821 I
think in all that time there has only
been one dismissal of a tenured faculty
member for cause the statistical
likelihood that in all those years there
hasn't been a second person that might
have deserved to be to be let go seems
improbable so and if you look at the
data across the country physicians
lawyers are the learning professions and
and academics only academics are
exempted from that kind of review and I
think probably for good cause I I've
become more skeptical about I must say
the government and the university
administration and about life in general
and and so I think tenure is probably a
useful thing but but not a life
appointment thank you
hi my name is Wendell wolf I am a
brother of Elliot wolf and I think you
were met you know Elliot wolf I do you
do and oh my brother well I have a
problem that was not tenured professor
but I wrote a letter to your successor
and I like to have find out what you
would have he would give me some help
no no I won't if you were to let it to
my successor you're gonna have to wait
for a reply from him
I did he didn't give me you're not going
to get it for me either not in public
anyhow no no unless you're praising him
and uh this is not a good this is not a
good forum for that kind of discussion
probably glad to talk to you okay okay
now yeah anyway I thank you for coming
here one of the things as we look around
this bookstore is books are commodities
and yet what distinguishes this store is
that books are a little more than
commodities so I want to ask you is
education a commodity
well increasingly and as I recently it
is yes go on
is it a commodity is is a University of
cooperation and did you run the
university as a CEO for corporation
thanks well as you know corporation is a
legal construct and yes of course
universities are corporations as are
hospitals and as are all sorts of other
institutions that we organize in our in
our society and and because their
corporation they have legal
responsibilities and they have eternal
life and they can sue and they can be
sued being a corporation is not in and
of itself an odious and over these thing
although having grown up in a left-wing
household I can understand how the word
can be used as an infective but but I
want to assure you it is a neutral it is
a neutral word and what you have to do
is get past that optic to determine
whether it is a virtuous or or not the
virtuous organization or not and one can
imagine corporations that do nothing but
the Lord's work and
is that our more melancholy and yes I
think universities to the extent that
they are fiduciaries and responsible for
the assets of tuition payers and and
philanthropists and and others have a
responsibility to run themselves in a
businesslike way but they are not they
are not businesses they have no
obligation to provide profits unless
they are in a different sector of higher
education to stockholders members of the
Board of Trustees not only are not
compensated but are expected to
contribute both their time and their
treasure to the University and so
universities are corporations but they
are distinguishable by their mission
they are they private universities are
private institutions in the public
service and and I think they have to be
viewed from from that that perspective
as to whether or not the degrees they
provide are commodities in some cases
they are and in others they are they are
not it's not a question that is
susceptible to yes and no yes and no
answer some of the some of the degrees
that we that we offer particularly of a
vocational sort are are more like those
comparably offered at other institutions
and interchangeable than others but some
are are unique and and handcrafted the
work of artisans and and and scholars
and I think are like books and and other
and other special items in our lives
unique yes sir
you referred earlier to an excessive
enthusiasm for athletics were you
careful to avoid a situation that you
see in a lot of institutions and which
athletics become such a prominent
business if not the controlling business
at the institution was that ever an
issue in any
sport there do you envy or pity
presidents who who have athletic
programs that seem to control the image
of the university if not its materials
yeah
success well there are universities
where universe where athletics is play a
very prominent role there's no question
that you're accurate in your question
but they tend to be also to some extent
mythical in the same way that that one
thinks about Harvard's endowment or
yells and talents they they are a
minority of the four thousand
institutions of post-secondary education
that we haven't have in our country
specifically as to George Washington
University I was fortunate that we did
not have a football team and so that
considerably reduced both the the good
news and the bad news the good news is I
didn't have a football team and all the
problems that come with it the bad news
is that school spirit is generally
enhanced by athletics and schools that
have football make a great deal of it
and the students love it
like alumni love it and this is not a
bad thing I never wanted to be the
president of the University of Nebraska
that seemed to me an inappropriate place
for me to play out my life but but I can
imagine I can imagine being a president
of an Ivy League institution I went to
three of them and and I remember with
great affection going to to the sports
events at the elbow or or at Baker field
at Columbia and and and there were
wonderful ways to spend days and with
classmates and girlfriends there's a
place for sports in universities but
it's like everything else you need a
golden mean you need to you need to find
a balance I think many of the
institutions in the country have left to
my own complete devices I have a great
affection for Division three sports
which do not provide athletic
scholarships and yet and yet as
president of GW we played in Division
one I did it quite consciously I I felt
I was to some extent being compared to
Georgetown Georgetown was playing in
Division one they were greatly
successful and and GW alumni always used
to say to me why isn't GW as successful
as Georgetown and and so we played in in
Division one and we had and I hope in
the future we will have some very
successful years Sports it's like
everything else listen I'm a social
drinker I don't I'm not a teetotaler but
there are obviously people who can abuse
who abuse alcohol or food or cigars so
all things in moderation could I ask one
question about there's been a lot of
research released lately about both
school preparation and workforce
preparation in other words the quality
of American public education producing
students who are able to deal with
higher education or deal with the needs
of the workforce and most of that
research has been very very critical do
you have any thoughts about what might
be done in terms of earlier education
before they reach the university level
which is generally lauded but before
they get there what needs to be done or
what can be done to prepare American
students better have you got a week or
two all right let me try and answer with
that thing to flip there are 50 states
and countless cities and villages and
I've lost track of how many school
districts there are in this country we
are a continent we're not friends we're
we're we we are a stretch the distances
that are twice the distance from Paris
to Moscow and and and so almost anything
you say about American schools is true
if you want me to cite the schools in in
Maryland or or the Bronx High School of
Science or the High School of Music and
Art in New York or the
rules of Winnetka a Scarsdale or Shaker
Heights I can give you schools that are
extraordinary by any standard national
or international and yet if we look at
the inner-city schools of Boston or or
Chicago or the Bronx we're going to find
schools that break our heart and make us
wonder do we love do we actually love
our children so the answer is yes and no
a lot of it has to do with very
complicated things having to do with tax
policy a lot of our school districts are
driven by the real estate tax as the
country ages more and more voters are
voting no on school bonding and similar
and similar kinds of issues because they
have reached a point in their lives
where the quality of schools don't
matter to them what matters to them is
social security and other social agendas
the the nature of Education it's not
directly dollar-driven
but let me assure you it makes a
difference how much you spend what you
pay teachers what condition the schools
are in and and I want to employ'd
applaud Mayor Fenty for having committed
himself as as robustly as he has to
enhancing the quality of education in
the district my concern is that if he
and Chancellor Rhee fail I don't know
where we go from there so we can only
wish him the very best thank you